my name is commander Khost wat phnom
originally from Bulgaria and I'm a
senior at MIT am majoring in biology and
next year I'm going to use yourself to
do a PhD in biology the reason I came to
MIT because i wanted to do research and
i knew that the biology department of
MIT is one of the best departments so i
actually started applying for europe
before i came to the states i started
working in professor Jack flap my
freshman year it was very hard on the
beginning because I didn't have
experience I probably my English was
extremely poor so is that link p21 or is
that she's working like link p21 right
as an undergraduate they should be
always supervised by someone and it's
definitely good idea I having someone
around in laughs when you're working
with chemicals when communicating to our
laboratory are interested in specific
tumor suppressor gene called p53 and we
were trying to understand how p53 works
in a prevalent cancer type called lung
adenocarcinoma I enjoy doing research
but I also enjoyed the fact that my
research can have impact on society and
other people's lives the goals of the
lab is to build mass models of cancer so
we're trying to recapitulate cancer in
the mouse and use the mouse as the tool
to study cancer so what we're interested
in is k53 and this is a tumor suppressor
gene the reason why it's called tumor
suppressor genes because it helps your
body against cancer so for so decides to
become cancerous and start dividing and
cumulates mutation this
gene gets activated and tells the cell
to stop and correct those mistakes when
it's always become cancerous very often
the sauce commit suicide they accumulate
mistakes and they're about to pass the
threshold of malignancy and then they
decide to kill themselves because it's
better for the body if it loses this bad
cells I think it's fascinating that a
cell in your pinky thinks about the
cells in your in your brain and what's
good for them the projects that I'm
currently working on is a drug screen so
I'm looking for small molecules that can
restore the function of this tumor
suppressor gene in vivo and be used as
an anti cancer therapeutics we are in an
academic setting and I think it's
important to train young people who want
to learn how to do science and having
access to MIT undergraduates in
particular is a real benefit to carry
out the research by using microscopy we
can local very thin slices of tissues we
staying for different pathways proteins
that get expressed look at different
interaction between cell types look how
the two more progress is based on the
morphology of the stalls what I learn
here is how to be a good scientist how
to ask the right questions how to design
experiments how to look critically at
your data how to communicate with your
peers and by doing research and
professor Jack rock really convinced me
that I want to stay in academia I really
want to be a biologist to be a scientist
you